PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
It's officially
week nine of Google
Cloud Next OnAir, which
means we're focusing on
business application platform.
I'm Priyanka, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week nine is all about the
business application platform,
meaning we wanted to help
your business be productive.
So we've got a content
lineup that focuses on
how to innovate with
an API-first approach,
as well as how employees can
create apps without coding.
Be sure to explore
the session catalog
for interesting advice
that could simplify
your own day-to-day work.
Our final spotlight is shining
on this authentication talk,
which breaks down the many
options and considerations
that your enterprise faces.
From understanding
the basic differences
to identifying what factors
matter most to your company,
this session is sure to
answer some of your questions.
My pick of the week is unlocking
the power of your existing
data through APIs because
it addresses a challenge
that we all end up
facing, eventually-
what to do with the
information that's locked away
in legacy systems or on paper.
It's really interesting to
see all of the solutions
that are available and how
different products approach
the same problem with
a unique perspective.
If you're like me,
then be sure to add
this one to your playlist.
Finally, be sure to check out
this video demo of AppSheets,
a tool that enables
employees to create
their own applications without
needing to write any code.
Even pro engineers like
tools that are easy to use,
and AppSheet packs a
lot of the features
into a deceptively
simple package.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or
tweet us using the hashtag
#GoogleCloudNext.
We'll see you in the cloud.